you will recall from earlier this week
we spent some time reintroducing this
idea of linear functions one of the
things I said who is that straight lines
can be stated can't express in a variety
of different ways
don't give me the names give me the
algebra what's an example of one of the
way we know to express the equation on a
straight line
so on yeah D this is a go-to for most of
us for good reason
from that you could read of course stuff
gradient and r1 is it the toughest give
it up in there okay oh very good coming
of course called this one zero home okay
let's get maybe they're more but let's
just get two more just two seconds right
there and I'll crack it next good okay
this one is great you could literally
see the point at the gradient just for
the sake of let's have one more
what's the newest one I told you what's
the newest one protectionism yeah okay
so I'll give you a clue it's a to the x
over bar what is a speed if I go to
instance just what is this one big
number signify in one sitting at home
it's answered the X it's the x intercept
right plus y over and finished just like
it is done why is that
what's it all equal to so we must have
been constant in time there's another
one that I miss you there but we
remembered that the point of these was
when you say it in a different form you
get useful information out of it
different kinds of the Commission we're
going to do the same thing for parabolas
when we get to that topic later on
except for one for this guy this guy's
like the most useful support right what
can you see off of this nothing there's
nothing is obvious to you but we make
you learn anyway
why think back to Wednesday money person
what what's useful about this ball
you can use the alias for biking routes
we need to go its directly to formulas
for your on derivative okay alright so
you're thinking of what we get to
calculus later on so will point out
calculus and differentiation whether
these things are very very important but
they are like the least important things
there's straight lines so straightaways
you don't really need any fancy
machinery for that okay on Wednesday
wanted mr. Dennis taught you a formula
to use there's perpendicular distance
right
I wonder if you are good enough now and
have had not practice during the
exercise to remember what the formula is
I've given you clue part of the fraction
what's on the top yes pause before we go
on to more okay so the whole thing has
to be taking absolute value but why is
that why do we just sort of you should
know that isn't it so it's a lake right
liquid positive because that's good on
the denominator okay so you've got a
point you have a straight line this is
the shortest distance between two so
we're pointing out there are actually
other fault of the perpendicular
distance formula but this is the one
that's there that is the course and you
can see why this requires general form
like you must be in this formal way sir
yeah all these pieces are measured these
aids are B's and C's those coefficients
have to be set up in this form those
aids of these are not these aids a bit
there's something quite different
okay so today we're going to go on to
another idea that requires the general
form and if this concurrent one okay now
I want you to remember one of these
words B because they will tell us what
current lines are what does it be with
two angles like criteria if they are
so it's together between a parapet or
knife so they're put together on the
inside of the power line or at kunia but
not the other is your mm what kind of
objects could be convenient eval yeah
we're at this point if you have one two
three points okay any two points in the
world are always going to eat
Kolia because you can draw a line as you
go through both of them but it starts to
get more interesting where you got more
the - okay if there are more than two
and they all exist on the same straight
line we call that Alinea together on the
line so conquer it what it refers to
line is when you've got a bunch of lines
and they are all together at a single
point okay so they all intersect you can
have as many as you like so I'm going to
give you an example to consider I'm
going to give you a pair of equations
I'm going to give them both to you in
general form the ski wire a bit later on
and I want you to help me work out what
would the concurrent wise be or to
paralyze me with the two equation I'm
about to give you so I prepared some
curly up here we go
this third line I'm going to call L 1
like 1 and it has this equation
he trouble okay now I'm going to push
this question to you piece these lines
are not parallel they're going to
intersect somewhere well at least if
they're in too deep
all right they're in 3d not parallel
lines don't have to intersect like my
heart's not parallel but they don't
intersect yeah but we're thinking about
a plane aren't we okay so these two guys
are going to intersect somewhere how do
I know that by the way without drawing
everything like that
I know these going to sit in it you can
even if you don't know the exact value
you can see that the grades must be
different right even though you don't
maybe can you cultivate it so if you
stare long enough it's not that hard
what's the gradient it's on your minute
think about it yeah you're going to sort
of mentally rearrange to get to here so
you're going to subtract that to both
sides you have to divide by two so
negative a heart whereas this one it's
just so great they're going to intercept
I don't need to a good intersects but
what I want is a third line that is
going to intersect with both of these so
I have this situation up here if they're
all going to detect a lot of me to find
this point where they're all together so
can you go ahead I'll give you two
minutes go ahead and find the point
anyway you like go for it okay I have
some coordinates I know what if you do
as well which is great you can do the
way that I've done it and interesting
when I was looking at your budget and
what cuz no one did it the same way I do
which is fine I mean most people who I
saw do you get the correct coordinates
but very few people actually decided to
go back the way that I did I label the
equators I thought well what is going to
be the quickest path I did anyone have
quicker working than that anyone right
yeah the push of a woman in England um
yeah okay so this is a pretty quick way
to do it let me put a big question to
you looking at the equations I handed
what clues are there in the question
that I should use what's this letter
called again this is a Venetian what
clues I know that elimination might be
an efficient way to go about this yeah
so so these guys here they're pretty
easy to get into shape I suppose I could
have been this multiplied by three it
would have been just as good but i hate
subtracting thing so I always mess up
double Megas it's just a thing with so
if I can see all of these are opposite
I'm just going to have to add them and
it's super easy just fall down so I
asked a few of you to start drawing if
you're not quite there yet you can as
well here's a look like so which one's
l1 and which ones help to tell me what
is the green one whatever L wonder the
blue ones you told me at the beginning I
agree of negative a lot and sure enough
and then she's not with gray in three
and you can't quite see it how do we
change the mode projectile yeah mmm you
can see just if you squid that the
corner actually so here we are in though
which quadrants again second quadrant
right first second third fourth okay so
far so good now we have this point but
that wouldn't work the question and one
the question was what's the equation of
a line that is concurrent would be two
okay now the question is a bit of usual
because there isn't just one line that's
concluded with this one right
in fact coming I doubt it then it
concurrent with this jr. numerous is
what way to put it
so diverse in fact there's an infinite
number of orders okay so how will we
find this out have a look at the board
I'll get this out anyway for a second I
want you to look back at the different
equations of wines that we have okay
the line you want with a wine C 1 can be
expressed in any of those ways you tell
me which one will be the most useful
I'm Grady
White Point Break you can substitute
three-point gradient will be most useful
because what information do I have about
this mystery line enter a point of 80 on
things really good to be that useful to
this not so much
okay so therefore this is the one I'm
going to go for I'm going to say it like
this every concurrent line with l1 and
l2
right they all share this ball because
they all pass through this set of
coordinates right I just don't know the
gradient all the red can be anything
alive so I'm going to write it according
to this form that I've chosen to use
okay also I wanna get just one
the M is unknown because any gradient
can still pass through this the Lord
satisfies this point part of the
equation so I'm just going to leave em
as M and then I have a here X if double
negative so this is a plus one and I'll
just pause there for a moment
obviously I could expand out that
right-hand side but because that's going
to end up as an M we're not really going
to be able to collect like terms anyway
because there's algebra numbers so
that's your secret so let's have a look
at this I'm going to bring this down 52
pieces is going to do what we expect no
this much
I know what showed you this briefly
before but not for a while if I say y -1
equals and then if you introduce a
pronumeral doesn't Duffus great d-twah
if you want to add that it's something
you can dynamically change so I love do
it in a second I need the rest of the
equation what was in the radix pretty
good so you've got that
plus the subscripts plus 1 go ahead and
do that so the first thing is oh that's
good
sure enough is concerned right default
des Vosges usually starts off at your
mystery cod Bishop b1 so have a look
what does that mean of this crap
your orange like that's what you want
what's doing great into one as it except
so now you can see I can just look about
with that gradient I can get it to
change
and no matter what the grading is
because in point grateful and I fix the
point to be that idea ok perfect amount